bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne la suite de l'examen du projet
de loi hôpital patients santé et
territoires la discussion reprend à
l'article 15 sur la question de la
démographie médicale et plus
particulièrement à l'amendement déposé
par le sénateur communiste françois
autain il souhaite que l'installation
des médecins soit soumise à
l'autorisation des agences régionales de
santé
objectif éviter que certaines zones
soient saturés alors que d'autres zones
manque cruellement de médecins
à suivre également un autre amendement
déposé par le gouvernement qui vise à
rétablir le caractère obligatoire des
contrats santé solidarité
une disposition qui avait été supprimée
par la commission des affaires sociales
du sénat
bonne séance à tous
la séance s'est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué il n'ya pas d'observation le
procès verbal est adoptée sous les
réserves d'usagé l'ordre du jour appelle
la suite de la discussion du projet de
loi adopté par l'assemblée nationale
après déclaration d'urgence portant
réforme de l'hôpital et relatif aux
patients à la santé et aux territoires
au sein de l'article 15 les amendements
numéro 4 174 à 180 ont été présentés et
les avis de la commission et du
gouvernement ont été données
nous en sommes donc qui arrivait aux
explications de vote sur ces amendements
alors je soumets aux votes de notre
assemblée le 474 de françois autain il y
a eu deux avis défavorables y at il des
explications de vote
monsieur françois autain
obama
sur l'eau je soumets cet amendement à
l'approbation de notre assemblée qui
pour l'adopter
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 857 rectifié qui avait été
présenté par paul blanc et plus
particulièrement par monsieur la mini
deux avis défavorables
y at il une demande d'explications de
vote qui est pour l'adopter
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 183 rectifié qui avait été
présenté par notre collègue monsieur
mort et deux avis défavorables
explications de vote vous avez la parole
la mëme ses chers collègues je voudrais
tout d'abord remercier madame la
ministre de d'avoir bien voulu hier soir
et tôt ce matin reconnaître la sincérité
du propos de ceux qui s'inquiètent de la
démographie médicale
je voudrais à mon tour dire
naturellement que je ne mets pas en
cause la sincérité de son propos et je
voudrais aussi rendre hommage à son
courage dont elle fait généralement
preuve et pour lequel j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration
en l'occurrence c'est vrai que j'ai le
sentiment je maintiens mon sentiment que
il est un petit peu quand même dans ceux
dans ses dispositions un manque de
courage par rapport à la situation
et j'avoue que je n'ai pas été convaincu
par le fait que le contrat de solidarité
serait l'alpha et l'oméga de la
démographie médicale
j'espère vraiment j'espère vraiment que
l'avenir me donnera tort mais c'est le
sentiment que j'ai je voudrais en
revanche
dire que pour reprendre l'expression du
rapporteur que c'est moi qu'ils étaient
outrés par sa réponse parce que ses
propos ont été tout à fait caricaturaux
personne n'a parlé hier soir de
nationaliser la médecine
l'amendement qui est proposée se
contentent simplement comme l'avait dit
lui même le président de la république
au mois de septembre de proposer pour
les médecins le même système que celui
qui est en train de se mettre en place
pour les pour les infirmières et je dois
dire aussi que j'ai été un petit peu et
même plus qu'un petit peu ou très
lorsqu'il a parlé de trous en parlant
des déserts médicaux
je crois que c'est quand même un manque
de respect pour pour la france rurale
alors c'est vrai qu'il a la chance
d'être élu d'un département où il n'y a
pas de problème de démographie médicale
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'il faut
oublier voire méprisé l'immensité des
autres territoires et je cette réaction
vraiment prouve et j'en suis un petit
peu navré je le dis très sereinement
qu'il y a vraiment des sujets tabous
pour ne pas dire des professions sacré
voir des vaches sacrées et j'en ai été
je dois dire assez assez attristé hier
soir je voulais le dire merci alors je
soumets cette approbation à
l'approbation de notre assemblée
cet amendement 183 rectifier il y avait
deux avis défavorables madame la
ministre vous avez la parole ah vous
voulez vous demandé un scrutin public
sur le 183 rectifier
peut être
savary
dt saisie d'une demande de scrutin
public par le ministre il va être sûr
concernant l'amendement 183 rectifier il
va être procédé au scrutin public dans
les conditions fixées par l'article 56
du règlement
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront aux secrétaires un bulletin
blanc contre un bulletin blanc
l'abstention à bulletin rouge de scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques instants
1 est ouvert
on
shi
puis
cher
le
il a raison
alors plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos et j'invite mesdames
et messieurs les secrétaires a procédé
au dépouillement du scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 175
l'amendement 183 rectifier à l'article
15 du projet de loi portant réforme de
l'hôpital nombre de votants 337 nombre
de suffrages exprimés
328 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés 165 pour l'adoption 39 contre
le sénat n'a pas adopté ensuite nous
avons le 2 rectifié terre qui avait été
présenté par notre collègue divers deux
avis défavorables qui est jean pierre
sueur pour explication de vaud merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
j'ai été extrêmement frappé par le débat
qui a eu lieu hier soir
parce que j'ai eu le sentiment mes chers
collègues que nous revenions à des temps
un peu ancien puisque il y avait si j'ai
bien compris les partisans de la liberté
et les partisans de la coercition
alors si on présente les choses comme
cela
naturellement je crois que on ne peut
pas régler le problème qui est posé
tout le monde voit bien que la liberté
d'installation qui est bien entendu un
sujet auquel les médecins sont très
attachés la liberté d'installation ne
suffit pas le aujourd'hui à créer le
bien commun en matière sanitaire parce
qu'il y à aussi la liberté d'être
soignés et la liberté d'avoir droit à la
santé qui est une liberté qui concerne
tous les citoyens de ce pays
et alors j'avoue ne pas très bien
comprendre que dès lors que l'on pense
qu'il faut que la liberté s'exerce dans
le cadre de règles dans le cadre de la
loi
on nous dit que c'est la coercition
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez parlé
de l' idéologie socialisante
qui conduirait certains à eux de voir se
rendre dans des trous comme a dit notre
collègue mort et j'avoue que cette
notion de trouble a aussi interrogé et
que je me suis dit que pour comment
monsieur le président oui vous avez
raison de rectifier
car désert médical est plus appropriée
car voyez vous nous nous a pour nous
sénateurs
il n'existe pas des trous quand nous
arrivons dans une commune quelle que
soit sa taille il nous arrive de penser
que c'est une commune où il y a eu des
habitants et il ya même monsieur le
rapporteur et monsieur le président des
grands électeurs qui n'apprécierait
peut-être pas tellement qu'on considère
qu'ils représentent des trous bon bien
donc je me permets de dire ça
amicalement
parce que cette question m'a choqué
mon cher collègue avec beaucoup d'amitié
cela m'a un peu choqué puisque nous
sommes les les représentants de toutes
les communes mais n'en faisons pas trop
vous avez raison bien sûr non mais tout
à fait dont d'ailleurs monsieur le
président à juste titre à rectifier il
s'agit des déserts médicaux
alors justement madame la ministre vous
nous avez expliqué qu' il allait y avoir
des études et que les choses allaient
changer parce qu'il y aurait des
analyses très fines et puis une fois
qu'ils auraient eu des analyses très
fines on allait présenter aux futurs
médecins le résultat des analyses très
fines et une fois qu'ils auront pris
conscience de la finesse des analyses
peut être les comportements
changerait-il et ainsi les choses
s'amélioraient rethel alors alain
ministre j'ai l'honneur de vous inviter
dans un canton où il y a trois médecins
qui vont prendre leur retraite dans les
trois ans qui viennent
moi je veux bien que vous en voyez que
tous les experts de votre ministère que
vous fassiez une délégation de liga ce
que vous veniez vous même mais il est
assez facile de comprendre
que si on ne trouve pas d'autre solution
eh bien il n'y aura plus de médecins
dans ce canton d'ici j'ai dit trois ans
d'ici cinq ou six ans donc je crois que
la question des règles se pose
assurément mais il est possible me
semble-t-il de dépasser ce vieux
clivages j'avais vraiment l'impression
que l'on revenait à une dichotomie
contre laquelle moi je me suis engagé
dans la politique parce que j'en avais
un peu assez d'avoir d'un côté le
libéralisme à l'état pur et de l'autre
l'étatisme à l'état brut
et moi je suis un social démocrate
voyez-vous nul n'est parfait mais je
pense qu'il est possible de concilier le
respect de la liberté et des règles qui
font que l'ovi correctement ensemble et
que même s'il n'y a pas de règle
eh bien on porte atteinte à un certain
nombre de libertés et par conséquent il
me semble madame la ministre mes chers
collègues que la bonne solution pour
avancer c'est justement la solution du
contrat hier je me suis permis
monsieur président de parler des
contrats que l'on pourrait passer avec
les étudiants l'état financerait les
études
une partie des études ils s'engageraient
ça va venir tout à l'heure ils
s'engageraient à servir dans certaines
zones où on a besoin d'eux il s'agirait
d'un contrat librement consenti vous
m'avez dit oui mais ça va coûter cher et
puis vous ne venez pas utile de payer
les études des riches mais on peut
mettre en place des systèmes sur
critères sociaux ça existe ça existe et
ça existe et ça pourra exister
là ce qui est proposé par monsieur moret
et nous allons soutenir son amant e de
rectifier terre ce qui est proposé c'est
qu'une fois que le schéma sera mis en
place et bien eux il y aura proposition
du contrat c'est un contrat de
solidarité contrat santé solidarité qui
permettra finalement eu une solidarité
des médecins à l'égard des endroits de
nos concitoyens qui sont dans des
endroits où il n'y a
pas de possibilité d'accès aux soins je
crois qu'il ya là quelque chose qui
n'est pas coercitive c'est un contrat
d'ailleurs vous même madame la ministre
tout en tout en disant que la coercition
ne vous plaît pas beaucoup et même en
dénonçant la coercition
après tout vous prévoyez de la mettre en
oeuvre trois ans plus tard on va voir
cela avec l'amendement de 230 pour
lequel vous avez donné votre accord
donc monsieur le président il existe une
autre voie et je crois que la voie du
contrat mise en oeuvre avec fermeté mais
aussi dans le respect des parties est
une solution pour avancer dans la voie
que nous devons tracer au delà des
positions peut être un peu caricatural
claude biver vous avez la parole avec ce
président là nos ministres mes chers
collègues ici nous avions déposé cet
amendement si j'avais un petit peu
réfléchi à tout cela dans ma région pour
ce que je vis journellement c'est bien
parce que nous ressentons un besoin fort
d'organisation dans la mesure où on ne
peut pas ou ne souhaitent pas pour
l'instant voir bouger le numerus clausus
qui serait peut-être une des solutions
nous sommes amenés à présenter un
certain nombre de dispositions qui
peuvent à nos yeux en tout cas fait
révolue et notre pensée et notre action
de demain j'ai le sentiment que nous
avons vécu nous voulons de le vivre avec
le vote qui vient d'avoir lieu qu'il y a
de ce côté là encore d'un travail
important à faire et j'entends dire
l'instant tu collectionnes dire
finalement on peut créer un consensus
autour de moi c'est un peu comme ça on
peut tous se mettre d'accord
si vous si vous êtes de mon avis alors
c'était un peu ce que j'avais pensé à un
moment donné mais j'ai pas le sentiment
que nous en sommes arrivés à ce point et
je dis que ce que je propose est ce
justifié probablement pas si si nous
avions véritablement voté l'amendement
précédent qui portait peut-être encore
un peu plus loin l'idée de réaction
d'action et qui nous permettait
peut-être d'évoluer un petit peu compte
tenu de tout ce qui se passe nous
comprenons très bien que l'on ait la
volonté pourquoi pas de d'habiter dans
un lieu de travailler dans un autre on
pourrait peut-être aussi réfléchir à
cela
je vois même des ruraux pur artisans
commerçants agriculteurs vivre à la
ville et travailler à la campagne et
bien les médecins peuvent le faire on
n'y voit pas un inconvénient majeur
et si on se résumait en entende approche
dans certains cas je sais que je vais
plus vite à mon chef lieu
d'arrondissement que je ne vais à un
arrondissement à côté de celui où
j'habite à paris c'est c'est donc
quelque chose qui peut encore se
retraduire autrement moi ce que j'aurais
souhaité c'est que ce débat pour
l'avenir apporte la volonté unanime d'y
réfléchir véritablement sérieusement à
partir des éléments vécu sur le terrain
à partir que la réglementation bien sûr
et tout reste et que nous puissions
avoir une politique un peu commune qui
nous conduisent vers un début de
solution parce qu'on sait que ce n'est
pas facile
moi je prends un petit peu c'est le jeu
dire l'apport extérieur aussi de gens
qui auront professionnellement
l'aptitude pour exercer mais cela est
dit dans tous les bandes cette assemblée
que
quelquefois ce n'est pas dans la même
qualité et bien la france à ce privilège
d'être un bon niveau et médicales eh
bien je crois qu'il faut que nous
essayons d'aller dans ce sens là et si
la raison pour laquelle je retirais mon
amendement en considérant que nous avons
un travail de fond encore à faire et que
nous devons le faire ensemble de
rectifier terre et retirer le 477 de
françois autain deux avis défavorables
vous avez la parole
certains dans l'explication de votre
merci monsieur le président le lay nice
donc c'est une deuxième chance pour le
groupe socialiste de voter un amendement
qui va dans le même sens que celui qui
était de poser par monsieur l'hiver
d'autant plus que je n'ai absolument pas
l'intention de le retirer bien entendu
alors je j'en profites en pour commenter
les les réponses qui ont été apportées
par le ministre aux questions que je
posais à propos de ce contrat parce que
à la différence d'un certain nombre
d'entre vous bien sûr je crois pas à
l'applicabilité à la faisabilité de ce
contrat et les réponses que apporter le
ministre aux questions que j'avais posé
ne se ne sont pas pour me faire changer
d'avis bien au contraire parce que si
j'ai bien compris si des médecins n'ont
pas la chance d'habiter loin des zones
sous-médicalisées bien ses médecins au
peu de chances d'être sollicités pour
aller exercer dans ces zones dans des
zones sous médicalisées donc il y aura
là forcément une injustice il y aura
certains médecins qui parce qu'ils
auront cette malchance de s'être
installé dans une région à proximité de
zones choisir eux seront sollicitées
alors que les autres ne seront pas parce
qu'ils sont trop loin donc c'est un
aspect parmi d'autres qui prouve que ce
contrat n'est pas applicable
alors vous avez aussi beaucoup critiqué
un certain nombre de mesures que nous
proposions en raison de
du fait que nous ferions comment que
nous sacrifierions la solidarité
intergénérationnelle
alors bon jeu je sais que vous êtes très
attentif à cette solidarité entre les
générations et je constate que vous
n'êtes pas toujours parce que quand il
s'agit de financer les dépenses de la
sécurité sociale
vous avez plutôt tendance à faire porter
sur les générations futures
le poids du déficit que les générations
présentes accumulent et c'est d'ailleurs
pour cette raison que vous avez créé la
kadey ce qui permet ainsi aux
générations futures de s'exonérer de
leurs charges sur aux générations
présentes pardon de s'exonérer de leurs
charges sur les générations futures on a
là un exemple qui témoigne que la
solidarité inter-générationnelle ne
fonctionne que quand il s'agit de
médecins quand il s'agit de patients
enfin quand il s'agit de jeunes français
elle ne fonctionne pas donc
et alors en ce qui concerne monsieur le
rapporteur
je suis très heureux que concernant
toutes ces mesures il n'est pas parler
d'idéologie communisante puisque sinon
nous serions senti visé je comprends que
les socialistes l'été quand vous avez
parlé dit d' idéologie socialisante et
moi personnellement je suis choqué et je
suis consterné de voir que le
gouvernement et la majorité reste
totalement inerte devant ce scandale que
constitue les déserts médicaux et
l'absence de mesures urgentes pour
s'opposer à cette situation
c'est la raison pour laquelle bien sûr
je maintiens mon amendement
bernard cazeau oui monsieur bee ware et
en ayant sorti son amendement que nous
soutenions
nous sommes persuadés de beaucoup de
choses
qu'a dit monsieur autant d'abord le
contrat de solidarité c'est quelque
chose que nous souhaitons mais il ya
encore beaucoup de brume là-dessus
derrière cela parce que le problème de
sa mise en place
madame la ministre nous a pas tellement
expliquer comment on va faire les choix
cela sera-t-il en fonction des résultats
d'examens ou deux
d'une liste
en fait en fin d'études bref tout ceci
est encore plein de points
d'interrogation pour nous mais nous
pensons qu'il faut comme l'a dit sur le
sueur qu'il faut contractualisés et je
crois même la ministre
certes vous avez donné beaucoup de
détendu de travail à ce pauvre directeur
de rs je le plains de beaucoup mais je
crois que ce sera une des premières
tâches qu'il va falloir faire qu'ils
fassent avec ses collaborateurs bien sûr
une des premières tâches c'est celle là
parce que c'est urgent vous leur portez
à 2012
nous pensons qu'il faudrait l'avancé
donnée nous ce sera peut-être déjà un
peu tard
certes vous voulez voir quels sont les
effets des mesures que vous prenez mais
les effets des mesures vous prenez comme
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs elles seront
différées parce que c'est pas du jour au
lendemain qu'on bouge 10 ans ou quinze
ans je veux bien prendre une part que
nous prenions une part de responsabilité
là dedans d'inertie dans le numerus
clausus donc nous souhaitons à travers
l'amendement présenté par monsieur
auteurs montrer notre volonté de
contractualiser et de le faire dans les
délais les plus rapides sur en fonction
de la mise en oeuvre de la loi et c'est
pour ça que nous soutenons nous
soutiendrons cet amendement il ya plus
explications de wauquiez pour adopter
l'amendement 477 de france aux hautes
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté le 8
158 rectifié de marc laménie deux avis
défavorables
merci je vois le président et même la
ministre chers collègues donc pour cet
amendement où ils sont 58 rectifier et
puis également le suivant 859 donc hier
le rapporteur madame la mission donner
un certain nombre d'informations et donc
la vue aux vues de de ces informations
et ça vaut aussi pour le le précédent en
1857 rectifié puisque l'objet était tout
à fait le même c'était un remplacement
des mots au niveau 2
état des lieux rejoints de la
démographie médicale bon c'était un peu
aussi le souhait de mes collègues
signataires de cet amendement paul blanc
et monsieur gilles pour justement
insisté sur la notion de démographie
médicale bon donc
mais au vu des explications qui ont été
donnés hier donc je retire je retire
donc l'on sait ces amendements lors un
bon hiver antérieurement lui 157
rectifier mais c'est la même chose que
pour le 858 rectifier et également le
859 dont je les retire
merci marc amélie ces deux amendements
s'en retirer hervé maurey le st80
rectifier il y avait une sagesse de la
commission un avis défavorable du du
gouvernement qui est pour adopter cet
amendement à face au tas simplement que
à mon sens à cet amendement n'a pas lieu
d'être puisque le schéma régional
d'organisation des soins ne sera pas
opposable par conséquent effectivement
c'est un état des lieux
donc à mon avis cet amendement est
satisfait par par le texte vient alors
qu'ils aient pour adopter cet amendement
le 180 rectifié qui est contre il
s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée le 4 182
françois autain deux avis défavorables
y at il des explications de vote
je d'envoi point je le soumets au vote
qui est pour l'adopter
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 6 126 rectifié de gilbert
barbier deux avis défavorables
il est retiré le support 26 rectifié
retirer alors nous avons deux
amendements identiques le 179 et le 230
rectifié nous avons celui d'hervé maurey
donc
avis défavorable de la commission mais
par contre un avis favorable du
gouvernement
y at il des demandes d'explication de
votre alain vasselle vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame le ministre
mes chers collègues sur cet amendement
de suppression qui n'est pas conforme à
la position de la commission des
affaires sociales tel que l'a expliqué
le rapporteur hier soir j'aurai me
permettent de faire un certain nombre
d'observations qui à mon sens devrait
être prise en considération avant que
nous puissions nous prononcer sur cet
amendement tendant à rétablir qui
refusent de signer un tel contrat
première remarque que je voudrais
présenter devant vous mes chers
collègues la ministre nous a expliqué
hier que le gouvernement ne souhaitait
aller s'en tenir ni uniquement à des
mesures incitatives ni s'engager dans
des mesures coercitives
en revanche on s'oriente semble-t-il une
des interprétations que je fais vers des
mesures à caractère dissuasif puisque si
un médecin refuse de signer le contrat
il devra payer une sorte d'amande une
pénalité pour le non respect de ce
contrat
tu veux dire qu'un jeune médecin qui
terminera ses études qui refusera au
bout des trois années d'évaluation
d'aller s'installer dans une zone sous
denses par le biais d'un contrat il
devra payer une pénalité 2e deuxième
remarque je considère que avant de
d'évacuer d'un revers de la main la
l'absence d'efficacité des mesures
incitatives
je n'ai pas le sentiment que nous ayons
procéder à une évaluation de l'ensemble
des mesures incitatives qui ont été
mises en oeuvre depuis quelques années
je rappelle mes chers collègues que
toutes ces mesures se sont ont été mises
en place progressivement les unes après
les autres
il n'y a pas eu un moment donné la
définition d'une politique incitative
globale qui aurait permis d'avoir des
effets réels à chaque loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale
nous y allions d'une mesure je pense
notamment à la dernière disposition que
j'avais fait adopter avec votre accord
ici palau assemblée concernant les
maisons de santé maisons de santé qui
avait fait l'objet d'un brillant rapport
de la part de notre collègue juilliard
et à l'époque lorsque j'avais introduit
dans la loi donc la nécessité
d'encourager ces maisons de santé
le gouvernement lui-même était un peu
frileux sur cette disposition et nous
avions dû lui forcer la main pour
qu'elle apparaisse donc dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale dans
les maisons de santé à elle-seule des
maisons médicales ne constitue pas la
mesure incitative miraculeuse qui a une
seule pourrait régler le problème c'est
un ensemble de mesures incitatives qui
peuvent donner des résultats
autre remarque c'est que nous sommes en
train de traiter la question de la même
manière pour le stock et pour le flux
alors madame la ministre a évoqué hier
qu'il fallait jouer la solidarité
intergénérationnelle
mais mettez vous à la place d'un jeune
étudiant qui a commencé ses études il ya
dix ans et qui dix années après des
cours qui ne va pas pouvoir s'installer
librement dans le territoire de son
choix
parce que des nouvelles mesures
contraignantes viennent s'imposer à lui
je comprendrais que l'on puisse
appliquer ces mesures sur leflux
mais pas sur le stock parce que
évidemment la forme de contrat moral qui
existait entre la société et ses jeunes
étudiants est rompu
il peut devrait y avoir à mon sens donc
une prise en considération de ces
situations et faire en sorte que donc
ces jeunes médecins ne considère pas
qu'ils ont été trompés
lorsqu'ils se sont lancés dans ses
études de troisième considération
monsieur le président et madame la
ministre ya fait allusion
les médecins internes et notamment j'ai
reçu personnellement la représentante du
de ses médecins internes m'ont fait
valoir qu'il y avait un manque de
diffusion de l'information auprès des
étudiants en ce qui concerne l'ensemble
de ces mesures incitatives et qu'il
fallait pas s'étonner de ce fait que
celle ci n'ait pas rencontré les effets
attendus
alors j'entends bien que la ministre
dans le cadre de ce2 ce2 cette loi a
prévu des dispositions pour faire en
sorte que le directeur de l'agencé
régionale de santé puissent assurer la
meilleure diffusion possible de
l'information pour que ces mesures
incitatives prennent leur plein effet
mais pourquoi ne pas attendre justement
leur plein effet avant de rentrer dans
des mesures à caractère un peu plus
contraignantes et je fais partie de ceux
qui pensent que la proposition qui était
faite par notre collègue soeur aurait pu
être une des mesures à caractère
incitatif que répètent plus de
considération qu'est ce que ce sont les
conseils généraux lorsqu'ils constatent
qui manque d'assistantes sociales sur
leur territoire
des contrats ont été signés entre des
jeunes étudiants prenant en charge le
financement de leurs études
moyennant quoi en contrepartie du
ces étudiants qui envisagent
d'intéresser le métier d'assistante
sociale sans galles a travaillé pour
cinq années dans le département qui
jacassent accorder le financement
pourquoi n'aurions nous pas pu imaginer
un dispositif de cette nature alors on
nous dit que ça va coûter cher on est ce
que ça va coûter vraiment plus cher
que ce que va coûter l'absence de
satisfaction de l'installation de
médecins dans les déserts médicaux et
les le contrecoup de la dépense que
subissent l'hôpital public mais ce que
vous savez bien que là où il ya des
déserts médicaux
là où il n'y a pas de permanence de
soins ben nos administrés n'ont pas
d'autre choix que d'aller à l'hôpital de
proximité pour se faire soigner
autrefois il y avait des dispensaires
que tu es répartis sur le territoire
enfin je vais terminer monsieur le
président en considérant qu' il faut que
nous réussissions à concilier la liberté
d'installation des médecins et la
mission de service public que se doit
d'organiser sur l'ensemble du territoire
le gouvernement et l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale
est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas lieu plutôt
que de contraintes des médecins libéraux
de veiller à ce que le service public
sur l'ensemble du territoire soit bien
assurée et de proximité de telle manière
à ce que nos concitoyens puissent eux
pouvoir bénéficier donc des services
qu'ils puissent qu'ils peuvent qu ils
peuvent en attendre voilà monsieur le
président mais chaque collègue les
éléments de considération que je voulais
développer devant vous qui ne m'a qui
m'amènera à ne pas voter l'amendement
qui est présenté par le gouvernement et
monsieur mort et madame la ministre vous
avez la parole d'abord je veux remercier
alain vasselle et lui apporter un
certain nombre de précisions
effectivement il ne faut pas critiquer
les mesures incitatives au motif qu'elle
ne serait pas efficace comme il l'a dit
très justement elles se sont déployés en
ordre dispersé les jeunes médecins ne
les connaissent pas ce que nous voulons
faire justement à travers la rs guichet
unique c'est d'avoir un interlocuteur
qui fasse la diffusion de ces mesures et
pour répondre également aux sénateurs
qui a ça jean pierre sueur le zonage
n'est pas une solution soit on du
stupide
le zonage c'était la diagnostique qui
permet d'orienter des aides et
d'orienter des politiques d'orienter par
exemple la construction d'une maison
médicale pluridisciplinaire pour faire
en sorte que des jeunes médecins y
trouve des conditions d'exercice
attrayante par zonage évidemment et
diagnostic du territoire qui est en lui
même en lui-même une solution alors
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une mesure
coercitive pour qu'on parle bien de la
même chose et mesures coercitives
elles sont de trois natures c'est à une
obligation d'aller exercer en zone
soudan n'aucun cas c'est cela c'est
deuxièmement et m une politique qui
n'est pas du tout la halle à notsé d'une
autorisation d'exercer une autorisation
d'exercer
ici la qui serait donné par
l'administration sanitaire
une mesure coercitive troisièmement sont
des mesures de déconventionnement
c'est-à-dire de frapper non pas
directement le médecin mais de frapper
sa clientèle qui n'est plus remboursé si
le médecin et et en zones sur denses et
ce qui serait évidemment totalement
injuste en aucun cas il ne s'agit de ces
mesures qui sont la définition des
mesures coercitives
ce que nous voulons faire ce sont des
mesures incitatives j'en ai parlé mais
nous voulons la garder la possibilité
d'une évaluation de ces mesures
ur incitatives pas renvoyer cette
évaluation à une évaluation dans dix ans
dans 15 ans parce que les problèmes sont
maintenant donc l'évaluation faut
qu'elle se fasse dans un délai et ce dès
l'âge de trois ans et on doute trois ans
nous voulons nous garder la possibilité
du contrat santé solidarité qui est une
mesure incitative plus musclée il ne
s'agit en aucun cas d'obliger les
médecins à aller s'installer où ils ne
valent pas mais ça n'a en aucun cas cela
parce que dans le propos dans la basse
elle le laisse supposer
il s'agit que les médecins installés en
zones surdenses ce qui représente à peu
près 3% du territoire de notre pays et
10 % des praticiens généralistes ça ne
concerne pas les spécialistes des
médecins généralistes et une partie de
leur exercice à négocier avec eux qui
permettent de répondre aux besoins de la
population qu'est ce que c'est ces
besoins de la population c'est la
participation au service d'urgence c'est
le fait d'aller exercer une demi-journée
en cabinet secondaire dans une zone sûre
danse à proximité de leur cabinet
d'installation s'agit pas de les envoyer
à 100 km les dents ce maillage fin du
territoire dans ce zonage que nous
allons établir la zones surdenses elle
est en limite de zones sous denses c'est
toujours comme ça la carte de la
géographie de la de la médecine c'est
évidemment une carte que les
spécialistes appellent en peau de
léopard
donc on est toujours à proximité de
zones sous denses
ici des à paris rue de vaugirard il ya
des zones sous denses à sept kilomètres
d'ici et vous les connaissez donc il
s'agit pas d'envoyer les médecins à 108
150 km comme gelé comme le lait entendu
donc c'est évidemment d'assurer par
exemple un service médical dans une
ehpad
il ya toutes sortes de moyens de
s'exonérer de cette de 2,7
obligation de cette obligation de
solidarité
alors effectivement nous proposons une
redevance pour les médecins qui
décideraient de ne pas faire cet
exercice c'est quand même une question
de justice mais moi je suis très
confiante je suis persuadé que le paquet
de mesures incitatives dont vous avez
justement dit à la basse elle qu'elle
n'a jamais été organisés qu'il n'a
jamais été organisée ce paquet de
mesures incitatives
moi je suis persuadé qu'il va avoir son
efficacité donc soyons confiants mais ne
travestissons pas ce qu'est le contrat
santé solidarité parole et à jean pierre
fourcade
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
bien que ne connaissant pas beaucoup les
problèmes de désertification puisque
dans le secteur dont je suis l'élu pour
beaucoup désertification mais il ya une
insuffisance de généralistes il ya une
difficulté à assurer les services de
garde est assurée la médecine de premier
recours
il ya deux choses qui me gêne dans le
l'article que nous soumet la commission
des finances et le mandement que vous
proposez je ne trouve pas tout à fait
naturel d'appliquer la même sanction à
ceux qui refusent de signer le contrat
et à ceux qui ne respectent pas les
obligations nous fit un plafond est là
et il est là vous tiendrez d'un os de
vouloir faire de la figuration je vous
remercie
c'est ce que je souhaitais et
deuxièmement l'assemblée nationale dans
ce texte a dit que les conditions seront
définies en conseil d'état
ce n'est pas le conseil d'état qui fait
la législation le conseil d'état vérifie
les décrets il faudra modifier le texte
et dire les conditions sont définies par
un décret en conseil d'état essayons de
faire une législation qui soit
convenable et ne votons pas n'importe
quoi merci
si le président nicolas a beau et
monsieur le président je remercie le
président fourcade de tout ce qu'il
vient de dire qu'ils sont de fait des
précisions tout à fait nécessaire et
pour effectivement écrire un bon texte
je voudrais tout de même indiqué mm la
ministre que contrairement à ce qu'elle
vient de nous dire ceci ne concerne pas
que les généralistes mais d'après le
texte l'ensemble des médecins donc qui
sont prévues comme prestataire des soins
de premier recours et donc qu'il y a pas
seulement les généralistes dans cette
affaire je le rappelle les médecins de
premier recours concerne d'autres genres
il serait souhaitable aussi président
que nous puissions obtenir avant la cmp
le ce qui pourrait être prévue dans le
dans le décret oui parce que dans la
boue oui oui mais ce que je crois qui
est intéressant c'est de savoir que nous
allons voter des choses qui peuvent
avoir un impact ou marginales ou
extrêmement important selon le rythme la
durée des vacations qui seraient
imposées éventuellement médecin donc si
effectivement le sait une après midi par
mois ou au
une fois par quinzaine ou mais ça
pourrait être une journée par semaine à
partir du moment où on peut imposer
ceci est de nature éventuellement à
déstructurer le travail d'un
professionnel
je sais bien qu'on on ne va nous
promettre que ce sera effectivement à la
marge mais comme on a tous vu et il
n'est pas question d'aller développer
une sorte de techniques du sapeur
camember pour essayer de combler un trou
d'enfer un autre ailleurs donc il nous
faut être raisonnable le parlementaire
les parlementaires que nous sommes sont
des gens raisonnables
les sénateurs donc je souhaite
simplement comme ça toujours été promis
que lorsqu on nous parle d'un décret sur
un sujet sensible on nous en donne
éventuellement le contenu avant que nous
adoptons la loi définitivement
merci monsieur le président gilbert
barbier
oui monsieur le président et cher
collègue madame le ministre ou en
personnellement je pense que l'on joue
un peu sur les mots parce que dire des
médecins qui sont situées en zones
surdenses si vous ne signez pas un
contrat de solidarité
vous paierez une amende je crois que
c'est ça relève quand même d'une mesure
tout à fait coercitives 1 c'est un petit
peu les excès de si vous dépassez la
vitesse sur la route vous risquez de
vous faire prendre
et vous avez vous avez une âme alors on
me dirait n'est pas très forte mais
enfin quand même
il y en a qui souhaitent l'augmenter
quand je pense que c'est pas ce le fait
que d'obliger un certain nombre de
médecins à aller alors je rejoins le
président à bout c'est combien de temps
c'est une fois par semaine soit une demi
journée
c'est une période d'une semaine je crois
que tout ceci n'est pas à l'avantagé des
populations qui seront desservies par ce
que un médecin qui valait une demi
journée alors vous parlez de jaune à un
peuple
couvrir qui sont très proches à 5 ou 7
km mais je peux vous dire qu'en milieu
rural le médecin si on peut l'obliger à
les exercer dans une zone sous densifier
qui situe à 70 ou 80 kilomètres de son
cabinet alors je crois que tout ceci est
d'un flou quand même très grand qu'il y
aurait sans être forcément contre en
plus de ça il ya un certain nombre de
médecins qui sont installées en zones
sur denses et je parle notamment aux
femmes qui sont installés dans ces zones
qui exercent qui ont des cabinets
souvent à mi temps quelles seront leurs
obligations par rapport à cela je crois
vouloir génial de imposer quelque chose
de général sans avoir une définition
précise de quels seront les obligations
eh bien je crois que c'est quelque chose
qui va être dissuasif et qui posera
problème
j'ajoute que alain vasselle a soulevé un
argument mois pour les jeunes étudiants
en médecine qui rend entre actuellement
dans les études qu'on leur dise au
moment de s'installer écouter ou ceux
qui ont su retire ou voilà ce à quoi
vous vous exposez si vous allez vous
installer dans cette zone
mais quand même un certain nombre de
médecins qui sont installés dans des
zones surdenses de peter 20-30 peut-être
40 ans leur dire du jour au lendemain on
attendait dans trois en europe
vous allez exercer le demi journée à
l'autre bout de
peut-être pas de la france mais du
département je crois que la mesure
paraît intéressante mais elle mérite
d'être sérieusement est fine et et sans
avoir de précisions plus grande sur
cette proposition moi personnellement je
voterai contre cet amendement
nous passons votre alors nous avons deux
amendements identiques le 179 d'hervé
maurey nous avions le 230 rectifié qui
avait été repris par le gouvernement un
avis défavorable de la commission
favorables ou très favorables je rajoute
le trait voilà très favorable du
gouvernement
alors qui est pour adopter cet
amendement
13 14 14
qui est contre ils sont adoptés
eh bien ces deux amendements sont
adoptés
voilà les 179 et de sa propre a été fier
sont adoptés alors le 784 rectifié qui
suivait donc avait été présenté par
bernard cazeau et satisfait le grand est
satisfait le grand 2 tombe ensuite nous
passons à l'examen aux explications de
vote des 181 d'hervé maurey y at il deux
avis défavorables
y at il des demandes d'explication de
l'autre à la vaisselle ce président
c'est pas sur cet amendement en
particulier mais juste un mot à la suite
du vote qui vient d'avoir lieu
deux remarques le président abou a eu
raison d'insister sur la nécessité à la
vie elle m'excuse d'utiliser le même
terme le même mot la nécessité à la
bière quand même sur des dispositions
aussi sensible dans une loi que nous
puissions avoir connaissance
simultanément à l'examen de la loi des
décrets d'application
j'avais été moi même à l'origine d'une
provision doit avec mon collègue hubert
haenel demandant à ce que dorénavant le
gouvernement et d'ailleurs ça a été un
peu repris dans le cadre de la réforme
constitutionnelle nous ayons les décrets
d'application qui accompagnent les
textes de loi donc je souhaite que le
gouvernement puisse de ce débat tirer
des enseignements pour qu'à l'avenir
nous puissions avoir connaissance de
certains décrets d'application ce que je
crains fort que nous ayons quelques
difficultés à appliquer ces dispositions
deuxième élément je vais terminer par là
monsieur le président j'appelle
l'attention du ministre sur les
difficultés qu'elle rencontre vont pr re
a de toute façon dans des zones sous
denses qui sont voisines de zones
surdenses je pense notamment en milieu
urbain
vous avez des quartiers sensibles est
difficile ou lorsqu'il y a besoin d'eux
on a besoin d'un médecin
souvent on ne trouve plus de médecin
parce qu'il ya le problème de la
permanence de soins où il ya le problème
de la de la présence du médecin
généraliste sur le territoire et lorsque
les personnes qu'est ce qu'elles font
appel les pompiers quand les pompiers
arrivent dans ces quartiers
c'est quelquefois pour se faire agresser
donc par des bandes de jeunes résultat
d'un certain nombre de professionnels de
santé qui ne veulent plus aller
travailler dans ces quartiers et je ne
pense pas que le contrat permettra de
régler ce problème le problème est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça ça fait
entrer des considérations beaucoup plus
complexe qui nécessitera que madame le
ministre et a travaillé également avec
sa collègue du ministère de l'intérieur
pour assurer la sécurité des médecins
qui auront par le biais d'un contrat
l'obligation d'aller travailler dans des
quartiers sensibles et difficile of a
l'obligation s'est pas d'obligation tant
que tel mais s'ils refusent ils devront
payer donc une pénalité
donc je pense que ce n'est pas aussi
simple et aussi facile que cela peut le
laisser sous-entendre par l'adoption de
cette disposition
mais j'ai bien entendu qui aura une
période de trois années avant que la
mesure s'applique et je souhaite que
nous puissions tirer un maximum
d'enseignements de cette évaluation de
ces trois années avant d'aller trop
rapidement dans l'application d'un
décret concernant cette disposition
hervé - savez la parole merci le seul
présent juste un mot pour rappeler
l'objet de cet amendement puisque la
nuit même courte est passé depuis
j'ai le sentiment qu'en fixant la
contribution à un maximum de 2008 159
euros on soit vraiment dans l'ordre du
symbolique par rapport au revenu d'un
médecin et si on veut que ce contrat
soit efficace il faut vraiment qu'il y
ait une
une mesure dissuasive pécuniaire plus
élevé et c'est pour ça que j'ai proposé
tout en laissant naturellement au
gouvernement par le moyen d'un décret en
conseil d'état le soin de fixer ce
montant je propose que ce cette somme de
2008 159 euros ne constituent
certainement pas un plafond mais au
contraire un minimum parce qu'encore une
fois s'il n'y a pas une mesure vraiment
dissuasive en termes financiers ce
contrat il ne marchera pas et je
souhaite qu'il marche
serge lagauche pour répondre un monsieur
hessel
j'entends bien les uns et les autres
mais on a l'air de traiter les médecins
comme des choses anonymes comme ça et
c'est qu'ils s'intéressent pas à leur
secteur qu'ils s'intéressent pas à la
population qui s'intéresse pas aux
urgences qui s'intéresse à rien et on
leur dit vous allez allez là dans mon
département il y avait effectivement il
ya des zones difficiles et on a
constitué à en discutant avec l'ensemble
du corps médical ce qu'on appelle les
samis c'est à dire les urgences du
samedi jusqu'à minuit et du dimanche
toute la journée jusqu'à jusqu'à minuit
c'est sami effectivement il y avait un
problème d'insécurité les qualités
territoriale la sécurité sociale ont
accepté de participer au fait qui est du
personnel en plus dense et sami pour
accueillir un personnel qui à la fois
garantit une certaine sécurité au niveau
du médecin les accords sont faits sur
l'ensemble des honoraires et le système
fonctionne sans contrainte
l'ensemble des médecins du département à
quelques exceptions près mais il y en a
toujours dans une profession ont accepté
effectivement à tour de rôle deux
participé aux amis et d'aller dans leur
secteur les samis il y en a une douzaine
sont répartis justement dans les
secteurs du département
mais effectivement il a fallu discuter a
fallu que tout le monde s'engage mais
les choses se sont faites je pense que
pour la suite on aura beaucoup de
facilité à organiser car les médecins ne
sont pas indifférents au désert qui peut
exister aux difficultés qui existent à
condition que la discussion ait lieu que
tout le monde accepte d'y participer et
des mesures coercitives
disons que elles sont là pour rappeler
qu'il ya une obligation mais je crois
que c'est simplement pour le rappeler
est que l'ensemble des médecins sont
suffisamment conscients de leurs devoirs
en matière médicale tout de même pour
effectivement acceptées qui est des
obligations qui soit revu puisque les
gars n'existe plus le système des gardes
qu'on avait avant n'existe plus eh bien
il faut adapter l'ensemble et travailler
également avec les urgences médicales
merci serge lagauche alors je me soumets
cet amendement on voit qui est pour
adopter cet amendement
deux avis défavorables qui et contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté alors
nous avons deux amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
deux amendements très proches je vais
demander à francs le 475 ses bougies de
gonthier maurin qui nous le présente
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame ministre mes chers
collègues le rapport d'information remis
à l'assemblée nationale le 30 septembre
dernier par le député marc bernier et
portant sur les conclusions des travaux
de la mission d'information sur l'offre
de soin sur l'ensemble du territoire
rapport adopté à l'unanimité des buts
par le constat suivant je le cite
force est de constater que les français
ne sont pas égaux dans l'accès aux soins
pire si aucune mesure n'est prise à
court terme ces difficultés
s'aggraveront du fait de la pénurie de
professionnels de santé qui résulte
d'une gestion très restrictive du num
des numerus clausus dans les années 80
et 90 nous approuvons ce constat et vous
l'aurez constaté nous avons tenté par
nos amendements de prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour y remédier hélas
toujours en vain je vous renvoie à vous
refus d'adopter les amendements que nous
avons déposés notamment pour garantir
l'accès des patients à des tarifs
opposables ce rapport évoqué
précédemment très complet a mis en
lumière une difficulté quant à
l'appréciation des zonages dead
financière en effet les critères retenus
et j'ai particulièrement en tête la
densité des généralistes leur activité
mesurée par leurs honoraires
ces critères donc n'étaient pas toujours
pertinent puisque le temps ne tenons pas
compte comme le souligne justement le
rapport des écarts de travail des écarts
de temps de travail ni des modes
d'exercice particulier pour les médecins
salariés à temps partiel le montant des
honoraires perçus ne donne pas une idée
juste de leur charge de travail
le rapport précise également et à raison
que les critères de densité d'activité
sont également jugés insuffisants pour
refléter fidèlement la capacité de
l'offre de soins de premier recours à
satisfaire la demande au sein du
territoire des critères complémentaires
devraient être pris en compte
fin de citation compte tenu des travaux
de ce rapport il nous a semblé pertinent
devait devenir préciser dans la loi les
critères sur lesquels sont établis ces
zonages tout en organisant la
consultation des agences régionales de
santé c'est l'objet de cette annonce
si le 526 rectifié bernard cazeau oui et
bien cet événement du même cru
sinon il en tic je crois que bon si il
est important de d'avoir de deux
nouvelles références pour ces zonages
parce que déjà la cour des comptes dans
son rapport de 2007 souligne ex zonage
était hétérogène et les méthodes
utilisées et peut-être pas les meilleurs
nous recensons des zones
sous-médicalisées devait être achevée au
premier janvier 2007 cet inventaire a
été retardé bon je crois qu'aujourd'hui
il conviendrait de s'interroger sur la
superposition du zonage existence zones
sous-médicalisées zone de revitalisation
rurale zone franche urbaine
bref tout ceci nous inciter à essayer
d'y mettre un peu d'eau de fixer
certains critères pour ce zonage et de
le soumettre pour avis bien sûr madame
la ministre la conférence régionale de
santé qui rassemblera dès qu'elle sera
mise en place et les élus locaux et les
principaux acteurs du système de santé
en région thies alors monsieur le
rapporteur quelle est votre opinion sur
ces deux amendements
monsieur le président nous avons déjà
abordé le problème de zonage dans le
titre iv et au niveau de l'article 26
donc s'il y avait ou il a été dit que
ces zonages entrer dans les missions de
l'agencé de la santé et que ces zonages
doivent apparaître dans les schémas
régionaux d'organisation de sanitaires
donc il n'y a pas besoin de le remettre
au niveau de l'article 15 c'est une
demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable
merci madame la ministre oui je vais
mettre un avis défavorable sur ces
amendements mais là l'amendement soulève
la question des zonages et je crois
qu'il est quand même important de
répondre au fond je vais donc prendre
quelques minutes monsieur le président
pour expliquer les critères qui vont
permettre ces zonages bon les
territoires on l'a dit certains
connaissent de réelles difficultés
d'accès aux soins
un certain nombre d'adrs existe on en
parlait à l'instant avec alain vasselle
des mesures d'état les mesures fiscales
conventionnelle des mesures proposées
par les collectivités territoriales
ces aides s'appliquent sur des zones
diverses également défini selon des
modalités diverses les zones de
revitalisation rurale les zones urbaines
sensibles les autres
urbaine ou plus récemment des réseaux
nages qui ont été réalisés par les les
mrs depuis 2005 et nous avons une
certaine expérience qui a été acquise
dans ce domaine et tout ça nous montre
que pour être efficace la définition du
zonage d'application des mesures
d'amélioration de la répartition des
professionnels de santé doit respecter
un certain nombre de principes
quels principes premièrement l'équité
nationale il faut d'abord évidemment
garantir une équité de traitement
à ce cours et est en tournée et assurer
la maîtrise des dépenses d'assurance
maladie
il est donc nécessaire qu'un certain
nombre de règles sont édictées
nationalement 2 des mesures qui viennent
soutenir des projets locaux
il faut également que les mesures qui
sont prévus pour l'installation des
professionnels soit un levier efficace
pour ces porteurs de projets et en
particulier les collectivités
territoriales et qu'elle puisse donc
s'appliquer en fonction de spécificités
locales en synergie avec des politiques
d'aménagement du territoire et vous
voyez il faut donc respecter l'équité
national et en même temps être à levier
d'efficacité pour ses politiques pour
ses politiques locales à niveau
troisième principe un niveau élevé de
concertation ne me lasserai jamais de le
dire il faut que cette concertation à
ceci les élus les professionnels de
santé et les usagers alors les zones
d'application des mesures d'amélioration
de la répartition géographique des
professionnels de santé sont élaborées
dans le cadre du sros du sros
ambulatoires l'organisation des soins et
donc dispensé enfin en réponse aux
besoins de la population les schémas
régionaux d'organisation des soins
comporte donc ce volet ambulatoire
définissant une organisation des soins à
partir d'une analyse des besoins et de
l'offre en santé le sros indiquent les
implantations nécessaire pour les
professionnels de santé les maisons de
santé les entre des pôles les réseaux
il détermine également dans ce contexte
les zones différencier d'applications
ces mesures d'amélioration de la
répartition
cette démarche garantit que la
définition des zones s'inscrit dans un
territoire de santé de proximité dans
lequel l'accès aux soins en ambulatoire
et penser collectivement et de façon
prospective et fait l'objet d'une
organisation connue de tous
parallèlement au niveau national sont
déterminés à la fois un socle de
critères communs j'ai à disposition de
ce qu'il souhaite
en annexe toute cette définition des
critères a donc des critères comme à de
définition des zones et une règle de
répartition de la marge de manoeuvre
d'ajustement des zones entre régions
celle ci pourra être basés par exemple
sur le pourcentage de population
concernée par les différents types de
zones en niveaux de dotation la
définition des zones dans le cadre des
territoires de proximité d'organisation
des soins ambulatoires d'une part la
détermination de règles minimales de
définition des zones et de répartition
de la marge de manoeuvre entre régions
d'autres pas sont les deux leviers qui
permettront de garantir à la fois une
équité de traitement entre régions et
une adaptation du dispositif aux besoins
locaux
car on est toujours dans cette même
tension équité et spécificités de
réponse aux besoins
donc voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
et j'ai bien sûr pour ceux qui le
souhaitent
en annexe de mon propos est à leur
disposition les critères communs de
définition des zones d'application des
mesures de répartition géographique des
professionnels de santé
merci alors nous avons deux avis
défavorables
nous allons mettre aux voix ces
amendements le 475 de françois autain
yaté des explications de l'autre qui est
pour adopter cet amendement
qui est contre merci il n'est pas adopté
et c'est le même votre jeu qu'on sait
c'est le même vote
il n'est pas adopté deux amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune
deux amendements identiques de 476
isabelle pasquet vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le rapport
d'information que nous venons de citer à
l'occasion de la défense précédentes
précise ce que nous dénoncions même un
de ces lieux que l'accès aux soins
peut-être limité ou rendue difficile en
raison de trois critères principaux le
premier des difficultés d'accès aux
soins dans l'espace qui se mesure en
temps d'accès un professionnel de santé
des difficultés d'accès aux soins dans
le temps liées à des ruptures dans la
permanence des soins à d'importantes
files d'attentes ou encore des
difficultés financières dans l'accès aux
soins
quand manque une offre de soins aux
tarifs opposables
l'amendement que nous soumettons à votre
adoption tient compte de ces trois
critères en tentant d'y apporter une
réponse
celle ci repose par la précision des
règles relatives aux conditions normales
d'accessibilité aux soins de premier
recours car il nous semble que vouloir
faire vivre un concept aussi important
que l'accès aux soins de premier recours
dont aussi qu'ils sont précieux sans
préciser dans la loi les conditions
d'accès est illusoire en nous
considérons que notre devoir est
précisément de faire vivre les droits
que la loi définit c'est la raison pour
laquelle avec cet amendement nous
voulons préciser que pour ce qui est des
difficultés relevant de l'implantation
géographique l'accessibilité doit se
mesurer en termes de distance et de
durée
je vous rappelle par exemple que le
rapport de monsieur bernier préconise un
temps de trajet d'une durée maximum de
30 minutes
pour ce qui est de l'accès cible
tu es en terme de temps d'attentes des
fameuses aux files d'attentes
nous proposons que le décret précisant
l'accessibilité tiennent compte de cette
exigence de consultation dans un délai
raisonnable quant aux difficultés
résultants d'entrammes financière nous
proposons que ce décret prennent en
compte le nombre de professionnels de
santé libéraux autorisés à facturer des
dépassements d'honoraires
il nous semble que notre amendement
répond parfaitement aux enjeux soulevés
par ce rapport rapport qui d'ailleurs a
été adoptée à lui ni à l'unanimité et
comme notre a maintenant se calque sur
celui ci ne doutons pas qu'il subira le
même sort
merci alors qui est-ce qui présente le
727 rectifié jacky le menn merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
notre amendement propose de fixer des
règles d'accessibilité des soins de
premier recours afin que la politique
régionale de santé contribue
effectivement à réduire les inégalités
d'accès aux soins
cette disposition pourrait constituer un
excellent filet de sécurité d'ailleurs
dans des territoires où le patient se
trouve à une demi heure à trois quarts
d'heure et peut-être bientôt à une heure
du médecin le plus proche
il s'agit d'une injonction aux agences
régionales de santé en particulier
elle vise armaillé et territoires et a
créé une obligation de moyens et
pourquoi pas de résultats dans ce
domaine
l'amendement fixe donc des règles
s'agissant de la distance et la durée
d'accès aux professionnels concernés des
délais dans lesquels ces derniers sont
en mesure de recevoir les patients du
pourcentage en fin de ces professionnels
autorisés à facturer des dépassements
d'honoraires si nous sommes résolument
opposés à ces derniers nous proposons
deux des mesures graduelles pour
commencer dans limiter le nom
l'amendement vise donc à instituer des
normes pour les délais d'accès aux soins
ce qui serait un réel progrès dans notre
pays
les services publics pour lesquels la
loi précise des délais d'accès sont en
effet rare la poste et les cabines
téléphoniques sont concernés nous
proposons d'étendre une telle
disposition à l'organisation du tissu
des professionnels de santé
ces règles de prendre en compte
l'ensemble des difficultés d'accès aux
soins rencontrées par les français
l'éloignement des professionnels de
santé des files d'attentes des
dépassements d'honoraires etc
il est recommandé que sauf circonstances
exceptionnelles les sros vise à ce que
les médecins généralistes de premier
recours soient accessibles en 30 minutes
au maximum
quelle est l'opinion monsieur le
rapporteur sur ces deux amendements
identiques sur le président merci juste
pour rappeler à nos collègues que ça a
été une discussion importante hier et
qui est fière vous aviez annie dans
l'article 14 que la proximité s'exprime
en termes de distance et de temps de
parcours
je veux bien qu'on le met dans tous les
articles jusqu'à la fin du texte mais ça
ne sent pas une ti ça ne semble pas
utile donc fait un avis défavorable dans
la mesure où c'est déjà inscrits à la
tique 14 madame la ministre elle-même
point de vue défavorable sur les deux
amants alors nous avons deux avis
défavorables sur ces amendements y at il
des demandes d'explications de vote qui
est pour adopter l'amendement 476
isabelle pasquet et 727 pretty fier de
jacky domaine pour contre ils ne sont
pas adoptées le 725 rectifier c'est yves
daudigny qui nous le présente
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à ajouter aux ars la
mission d'accompagnement et le soutien
aux opérateurs de terrain en effet avant
d'organiser ou de contrôler l'âge ans
doit accompagner faciliter la dynamique
de transformation de notre système de
santé
pour cela elle doit constituer avec les
professionnels des outils qui rendent
possible cette nouvelle organisation des
soins avec l'aide des établissements et
des services médico sociaux
ces instruments constituent en effet un
socle pour que le dialogue puisse
établir entre la rs et l'ensemble des
acteurs de la santé usagers et patients
professionnels et autres interlocuteurs
institutionnels élus par exemple un
outillage renforcée
permettra d'assurer un meilleur suivi
des délais et la recherche de réponses
mieux adapté aux besoins et aux
calendriers de chaque partenaire mise en
contact recherche d'informations et
c'est la définition d'un tableau de bord
de suivi de l'activité associant par
exemple expérimentations et évaluation
constituera un autre axe fort de cette
coopération
cela permettra aussi par la mise en
place d'autres outils une meilleure
organisation de soins sur le territoire
incriminés née d'une réflexion
collective sur les marges de progrès de
l'institution et sur ses ambitions
stratégiques
ces outils ont vocation à faire en sorte
que les objectifs de chacun soient
clarifiées et à soutenir le
développement professionnel des agents
et des experts qui s'associe aux
missions de la rs outil fédérateur et
démocratique pour l'ensemble des
collaborateurs de l'institution en tant
qu il met en tension les services de la
rs la mise en place d'outils fixera la
feuille de route à suivre pour les
acteurs locaux de la santé merci sera
panther ya je voudrais juste dire à
notre collègue de vigny que je comprends
qu'on puisse reparler des missions des
ars puisque quand les amendements ont
été déposés
nous n'avions pas encore demandé à ce
que le titre un titre iv soit discuté
avant le titre deux titres toi mais
l'amendement qui est proposé donc par
des missions des ars qui ont été
définies lundi 26 on en a parlé toute la
semaine dernière il nous semble
satisfait cette demande de retrait ou un
avis défavorable
un ministre oui les préoccupations de
ceux présentés par monsieur
finissez par monsieur de tennis excusez
moi je n'étais pas tourné vers où
j'aurai bien donner un avis de sagesse
parce que ça correspond un amendement
sur lequel j'avais donné un avis positif
à l'assemblée nationale mais
véritablement le travail qui a été fait
en commission a franchement satisfait
votre amendement monsieur d'houdini donc
je vais plutôt être sur l'avis de la
commission pourrait vous demander un
retrait je suis président remercie donc
j'accepte de retirer l'amendement 125
rectifier et retiré alors nous avons
deux amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune plus précisément un
amendement 182 rectifié bis c'est hervé
maurey qui nous le présente
merci monsieur présent même la ministre
mes chers collègues nous en venons à un
amendement important non pas que les
autres ne l'étaient pas mais celui là me
semble particulièrement important
certains le jugeront d'ailleurs
politiquement incorrect mais il trouvera
au moins monsieur autun qu'il y à aussi
dans la majorité des gens qui se
soucient des déserts médicaux et que
vous n'avez pas le monopole de la
préoccupation concernant les déserts
médicaux
cet amendement est bien il propose qu'à
partir de 2017 les jeunes diplômés haye
pendant une durée de trois ans dans un
secteur sous médicalisées
cette proposition elle elle s'appuie sur
un certain nombre de constats qui ont
déjà été rappelés notamment par moi-même
cette nuit à savoir le fait que les
mesures incitatives à mon avis ne
produiront pas plus d'effet qu'elles
n'en ont produites jusqu'à présent et je
voudrais juste citer ce qui a été dit
dans le rapport bernier épaules
l'un étant je le rappelle ump et l'autre
socialiste donc on ne peut pas accuser
ces rapports de parti pris il disait
notamment
il n'est pas possible de corriger les
inégalités sans cesse croissante dans la
répartition des professionnels de santé
notamment des médecins par les mesures
purement incitatives sans que la liberté
d'installation des médecins ne soit
encadré et je voudrais également cité un
rapport de l'académie de médecine
un rapport de mars 2007 j'ai bien dit
l'académie de médecine qui disait le
choix de devenir médecin
écoutez moi bien cher docteur le choix
de devenir médecins imposent un
engagement de service à l'égard des
malades de notre pays
en outre la formation de chaque étudiant
en médecine représente pour la société
une charge financière importante
plus de deux cent mille euros c'est
toujours l'académie de médecine qui
parle à l'exemple de ce qui existe pour
certaines grandes écoles il ne serait
pas anormal que chaque jeune médecin
consacre quelques années de son début
d'activité au service de la nation
voilà ce qui est écrit dans un rapport
de l'académie de médecine de 2007
comme quoi les médecins sont parfois
lucide et ne sont pas tous aveuglé par
un corporatisme extrêmement regrettable
et préoccupant je voudrais ajouter pour
terminer je voudrais ajouter pour
terminer que cet amendement prévoit bien
que ce dispositif se mettrait en place
en 2017
certains de mes collègues comme claude
biver dacia sous-amendé cet amendement
trouve que c'est un peu tardif c'est
vrai que ça me semble un peu tardif et
si j'ai moi même mis cette date de 2017
c'est pour deux raisons la première
c'est que ça ne touchera pas des
étudiants qui sont déjà engagés dans un
cycle donc il n'y aura pas un effet
rétroactif qu'on pourrait reprocher à
cet amendement en disant des jeunes
engagés des études longues et difficiles
et on la pose une nouvelle contrainte
non ce sera uniquement pour les médecins
qui s'engageront demain dans cette voie
et dernière arguments 2017
eh bien ça permettra de voir si les
mesures incitatives dont on nous promet
l'efficacité le sont réellement
parce que si les mesures incitatives
proposées par le gouvernement sont
efficaces et bien cette disposition aura
pas lieu de s'appliquer
donc il y a toutes les raisons de
cet amendement si claude biver vous de
vous présenter votre fouet amendements
l'uni je crois qu'il est déjà
partiellement présenter mon collègue
mouret vient de dire deux choses nous
avions fait un amendement séparément
nous avons constaté qu'il se ressembler
mise à part des dates ou des délais et
donc j'en ai fait un sou un moment c'est
vrai moi je pense comme lui que on a
tous plus ou moins en fonction des
études longues
une dette envers la société et qu'à
partir de là n'y a pas lieu de renvoyer
cette dette
moi je sais qu'à une certaine époque ce
n'était pas la même chose évidemment
j'en conviens mais on m'a pas demandé
mon avis pour passer deux ans et demi en
algérie on m'y envoyer et là c'est pas
le cas on est en train de dire et il y à
un retour parce que le territoire a
besoin de vous messieurs les médecins de
demain
alors on aurait dit ma 2017
et moi je disais nul n'est censé dit en
d'ignorer la loi ni même ses les
prévisions de la loi et son évolution
dans certains cas et je considérais que
il valait mieux que ceux ci soient pas
appliquées le jour où seraient également
appliquer les textes que nous allons
voter
très prochainement je pense là
maintenant et c'est pourquoi je disais
pourquoi 2007 17 pourquoi pas 2012
pourquoi pas 2010 mais mais
peut-être 2009 si les médecins ne
souhaite je prends acte de la médecine
swing pour me dire que je vois trop loin
il n'en est pas moins vrai qu'il y a
quand même un besoin français de la
france entière pour que le territoire
soit arrosé normalement il n'y a pas non
plus d'obligation pour que les médecins
habite en ville et exerce en campagne
comme le font beaucoup de sociétés qui
est exprime une autre profession c'était
là l'objet de mossou un moment alors
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis sur
cet amendement et sous à vendre je vais
pas recommencer comme hier soir parce
que pour l'instant je suis encore en
forme mais mais je voudrais alors je
vais je vais quand même répondre à
monsieur à monsieur moore et monsieur
l'hiver d'abord la première chose ce
n'est pas la première fois depuis le
début de ce débat que j'entends
peut-être pas oui à tendance et c'est la
première fois en séance mais en dehors
de la science que nous entendons des
reproches faits aux étudiants en
médecine de faire des études en médecine
pour devenir médecin dire clairement si
vous dites que ça coûte à la société
200000 euros pour faire un médecin si ça
vous coûte trop cher n'en fait plus
clairement si vous n'en voulez plus ben
en fait plus vous payez des études
l'état paye des études pour faire des
directeurs d'hôpitaux pour faire des
agrégé de mathématiques etc
elle paye les études pour faire des
médecins qui après rendre service à la
société en exerçant leur métier
clairement arrêtons de dire qu'un
médecin coûte 200 mille euros à la
société pour faire 15 ans d'études
d'abord dans ses 15 ans d'études les
trois ou quatre premières années sont en
effet des années stérile pour la société
selon votre conception à partir de la
quatrième année il commence à travailler
dans les hôpitaux ils sont un petit peu
salariés à ce niveau là mais quand même
il commence à rendre des services à
l'ensemble des modes des malades
ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point s'il y a en effet des
zones des secteurs géographiques qui
souffre d'un nombre d'un manque de
médecins il y a dans ce pays des
secteurs géographiques qui ont un nombre
considérable de chômeurs où on a créé
des zones franches pour les entreprises
créant des zones franches plutôt que
d'obliger les médecins à aller plutôt
que d'obliger à faire des choses comme
ça crée des zones franches et ne
paieront plus l'impôt ils paieront plus
osés et puis en plus cela puis on verra
bien ce que ça peut donner
et puis enfin le dernier point est
excusez moi de le dire comme je le
ressens mais la mesure que vous proposez
c'est une sorte de travail obligatoire
non j'avais pas dit je l' ai pensé mais
j'ai pas dis et je vous autorise à le
penser par contre est donc tout cela
monsieur ne peut avoir de ma part et de
la commission d'ailleurs puisque la
commission a voté sur le sujet qu un
avis défavorable également pour monsieur
biver bien qu'il ait réduit à des qu'il
soit passé lui à 2000 est aussi fils
finalement est encore pire
madame la mise
oui nous sommes dans ces amendements ce
monsieur morel hubert c'est
effectivement la définition des mesures
coercitives dont j'avais fait le panel
sur les amendements précédent je veux
dire que je crois fondamentalement que
ces mesures coercitives seront
inefficaces
c'est pas que je les trouve moralement
indéfendable pas du tout prêts tout ça
existe dans d'autres ça existe dans
d'autres professions
c'est que finalement vu la structuration
de notre territoire
vu le mode d'exercice médical cela
creusera encore plus la désertification
du des zones rurales
je ne vois pas du tout étant donné les
concurrences qui s'exerceront entre les
différents modes d'exercice de la
médecine entre les différentes
catégories de deux territoires
les concurrences qui s'exerceront dans
l'espace économique européen
au niveau des professionnels de santé
oms comme en connaît les tensions nous
ne ferons que fuir un peu plus les
médecins de l'exercice de la médecine de
premier recours et nous aurons
évidemment un effet désastreux à terme
sur la démographie médicale
voilà donc la raison pour laquelle je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ces amendements
vraiment une démarche très
opérationnelle très pragmatique alors
deux avis défavorables ont passé aux
vôtres tout d'abord sur le
sous-amendement de claude biver y at il
des demandes d'explications de vote donc
gilbert barbier ensuite claude biver et
hervé maurey oui monsieur le président
mes chers collègues on aime le mini je
crois qu'il s'agit là d'une mesure
premièrement tout à fait irréaliste sans
parler de philosophie mais obliger les
étudiants à la fin de leur troisième
cycle d'aller passer trois ans dans un
secteur désertifier qu'en est il de ceux
qui envisagent de faire une spécialité
et reviennent en faculté après
seront ils dispensée de cette obligation
c'est une véritable question
deuxièmement je crois pas que ça puisse
donner ça puisse rendre service à la
population
voici des jeunes qui vont aller exercer
trois ans qui vont prendre des malades
en charge puis après pour des raisons
personnelles
ils vont quitter cette zone et on
remettra encore un et un étudiant en fin
de fin d'études pour une période de
trois ans je peux vous dire qu'au niveau
du service apporté à la population de
ces zones désertifiées ça ne sera pas
terrible parce que je crois que la
médecine
il ya une certaine continuité il ya une
connaissance une connaissance de la
clientèle qui joue un rôle important et
à mon avis ce genre de proposition ira
dans un sens négatif pour ces zones non
seulement dans la qualité des soins mais
aussi dans le fait qu'un certain nombre
de mesures qui peuvent être comme le
rapporteur les a évoquées pour inciter
effectivement des médecins allaient
s'installer là mais d'une manière un
petit peu plus pérenne claude biver et
ses présidents
ça ça me permet en même temps de
d'apporter une petite réponse mon
collègue barbier parce que nous ne
voulons pas exiger quoi que ce soit nous
voulons être bénéficiaire d'un service
dont nous avons tous besoin et jean
verserait un peu vos propos en vous
disant notre objectif second c'est
peut-être aussi d'inciter les futurs
médecins à venir s'installer au départ
en campagne pour qu'il s'y trouve bien
dans une qualité de vie différentes et
pour qu'ils y restent on n'a pas dit
qu'on les renvoyer au bout de trois mois
ni trois ans on souhaite qu'une chose
donc souhaitant qu'une chose c'est qu'il
reste
ceci est en jeu je reconnais que il y a
dans notre amendement dans mon sous
amendement également peut-être un effet
provocateur parce que le délai parce que
la difficulté s'impose moi je n'ai
jamais parlé de travail obligatoire j'ai
même dit que on pouvait habiter un
endroit exercer ailleurs je crois qu'il
ya eu toute liberté quand même d'agir de
s'exprimer d'une certaine manière mais
compte tenu de tout cela je crois que le
débat a éclairé madame le ministre vient
de dire aussi le côté pratique qu'elle
affichait à sa réponse
en conséquence de quoi je retire raymond
chésa moment sous-amendement 12 121 est
retirée c'était l'examen du projet de
loi hôpital patients santé et
territoires pour revoir cette séance
notre site internet publicsenat.fr
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt sur notre antenne